[Music]
in fighting for fairness news submitted
by JK is the only way Busbee has agreed
to recognize an employee union ending a
month-long
standoff I'm dude so I guess all those
like why I left BuzzFeed videos really
started speaking to them which ones
there's like a string of wire left
BuzzFeed why I left me like why I left
it's like I like a lot of famous
BuzzFeed people that left and then they
started there they kept their own or
maybe they continued their own channel
or whatever it was they decided to go
off on their own and then they all made
like videos of why I left BuzzFeed and
then you'll see like a ton of these
folks it's usually just like a very
long-winded 40 minute video that
ultimately you got the point like really
quickly that they didn't get paid enough
is basically yeah they all had their
different reasons like some people
didn't feel respected some people felt
like they were overworked and is a huge
company ginormous huge yeah yeah so it
was a five-month long battle between
BuzzFeed's management and its workers
and the blue-haired workforce yes they
did it yep they finally did it they
created the news guild which is now a
union for BuzzFeed and so they're also
this is also really huge because in the
whole tech world right now there isn't a
lot of protection for these employees
like other traditional types of
industries where there will be unions
here and so it's a really big deal that
they have finally come to an agreement
you hear the same stories like in
Amazonas stuff they will feel overworked
or not appreciate
exactly so they said so last month they
there
this for our protest that these workers
did to get BuzzFeed to listen because
they're just sick and tired of it and so
they the tensions have also been really
high because BuzzFeed cut 200 employees
or about 15% of its workforce back in
January after it missed revenue targets
and in March 9th of editorial workers
submitted pledge cards in support of a
union and so finally now hmm
they have come to an agreement to have a
union down they don't wanna do that per
article [ __ ] anymore where they get paid
per article they submit nah yeah it's
been a big thing and I know a lot of
different online places like Kotaku and
like all that [ __ ] they all kind of do
that BuzzFeed ian's thing where they
have a bunch of freelancers who they
they build their articles one at a time
and so these guys gonna crank like crazy
amounts of articles just to get paid
like decent amount of money yeah and
enemy some of our friends are with them
too and they created shows behind them
and all that but it's it's kind of like
one of those things where traditionally
IP is owned in intellectual property is
owned by the company that you're working
for but then with this digital age to
like people are more like hey I'm the
face of it I created it this is my idea
but why do you own it there's that gray
area there's just a lot of things I
think that's changing so I don't even
know the specifics of what's going on
but I think when any any time people
unionize it's because of
miscommunication and people feeling like
cheated dude I wish we had a [ __ ]
Union when I was at maker that [ __ ] was
crazy the stuff that was going on there
as far as like the amount of time that
you work on things and then the
different projects that you work on and
then you that the company gets like
retains all ownership of all those
things and so you're putting a lot of
time in but then you're you have no idea
of things it's pretty it's pretty nuts
it makes you feel eventually like you're
not part of it even though you felt like
you
part of it mmm what you were building
everything yeah so they're saying that
they finally were able to like the
BuzzFeed CEO dropped his opposition once
the Union agreed to leave workers on
Daily Show on Twitter and a weekly show
on Facebook out of the bargaining unit
that's what they're reporting so once
they get the ones they were like alright
cool we have to do that then that's when
they were don't those workers like [ __ ]
like we're out like wait so what does
that mean I don't quite understand
obviously they're making hell of money
from those shows and the guy's like hey
as long as you don't [ __ ] with these
people who were paying nothing to [ __ ]
with all these others people will pay
you guys okay and these guys like yeah
sure [ __ ] yes so this is only for
about 80 US News Side employees mmm
that's who's being in the ATP it's not
like our friend Steven whereas like
worth it how many employees Lee's a $10
robin versus a thousand dollar ramen or
like those kind of ones if they cut 200
employees they probably had like [ __ ]
who know it's 1,200 yeah cuz cutting 200
was only cutting like right damn
so dude they got 80 people in this union
and they're [ __ ] putting banners up
and cheering and [ __ ] what about all the
other people holy [ __ ] like a thousand
more employees at least 200 people is
15% of their employees yeah this is just
the news portion you know they have so
many oh yeah a lot there's BuzzFeed food
and all kinds damn wait so this is us
this is not all of buzz no news so they
turn into a union so that's why it's
called news guilds of New York do you
guys like unions because I guess I mean
we're kind of the same we're like yeah
we're JK news right and then we have a
whole staff of like editors and all that
stuff and I don't know like what okay so
I do know for example like a union out
of 9 to 5 even if you do something and
the boss is like I'm gonna fire you for
that you go straight to a union right so
the union's job is basically to protect
your rights at the workplace well
there's already employee rights at the
workplace right there's generally rules
that you can't violate like I forgot the
the acronym but there's an employee
agency that protects employees that's
deep ocean break room walls yeah like
they have all the rules yeah something
like that but I think what a union does
is per industry or let's say like the
teachers union or the longshoremen which
are the guys that work in the docks or
there's the the the actors in Hollywood
that sag a screen a shield yeah yeah the
right so there's bees you reproduce
Gilda's all right
so there's all these different unions to
protect everyone that's a part of that
union so like the teachers they could
all work together on like protecting
each other like their pay and their
benefits yeah stuff like that yeah I
think it's all situational right yeah
like as far as like when it's a good
time to unionize and all that stuff that
it depends on what's going on at the
company yeah cuz I I don't know like I
have mixed feelings about unionizing
because I think like they usually start
with a really good reason to get
together cuz you know like in the past
like you know companies exploited people
yeah there was a bird yeah there was
people losing fingers and hands on the
line on assembly lines yet and they're
just like hey you're fired by the way
because now you can't work the line yeah
see you later
like some unions were the most necessary
ever right and a lot of great cases
obviously but then when they get too big
there's strength and being a victim so
like for example one of the biggest and
strongest unions are the longshoremen
which they work at the docks right but
they kind of cheap a system where it's
like hey guys stop working too hard
because we want to milk this oh yeah
yeah yeah also it's like gum if you're
if you get the job done
- please don't give you my job then you
I won't work yeah so the union controls
their pace everything and then that's
how they use the negotiation of you want
these jobs done or whatever and then
these guys are making like six figures
plus four you're making a lot of money
eighty an hour some [ __ ] it's good for
the guys that are working there and then
I worried cuz I knew someone that like
their family worked in that and you have
to you can't just apply and like hey I
got this job like you have to be
recommend like there's like a laundry
list of like a waiting list where it's
like so people want that job so bad and
in the Mafia infiltrated some unions
because they can you know do things like
this and and it's basically borderline
extortion you know there's a lot of
workers to where it's like it's almost
like well we were talking about before
with the Boston Tea Party it's like
taxation without representation a lot of
workers feel like they pay unions but
then the Union doesn't do much for them
depending on what the [ __ ] yeah yeah I
think you also have to be right yeah
dude you were just mentioning yeah
everyone has to pay to the Union like
the screen actor or whatever any if
you're part of a union you pay fees yeah
and then that one owes to pay like for
the lawyers for everybody to protect a
union
yeah I know a lot of people who are part
of sagged who don't get medical benefits
because they're in sag but if you don't
book a certain amount of work a year
you're not getting the medical benefits
so a lot of people who pay their sag
dues feel like what the [ __ ] do I do
this for because I don't get any better
like a thousand dollars a year so it's a
lot yeah it's a couple of thousand I
think now yeah but yeah so it's a lot of
a lot of those people feel like their
money's not representing them well and
they could they could actually buy a
health care plan if they were able to
keep that money for example so that's
it's a definitely - it's not just an
easy street answer yeah like I like
unions cuz it does protect employees to
a certain extent what I don't like about
it is how rigid some of it can be so for
example like with us we've been trying
to write a film and been trying to write
a series but the starting point for an
established industry is now this much
higher because there's all these Union
rates so technically like all the people
that
submitting to film festivals that are
just doing passion projects with all
their friends and no one's getting paid
and we all I just want to make a cool
film technically they're all breaking
the law in the eyes of the entertainment
business because no one is getting paid
Union rates or doing anything the Union
Way and they control the Union so that's
the one side of it where I don't like
where I'm like I wish there was more
flexibility where there could be like
something that's considered like the
non-union way of doing things and then
once industries become big and
established like maybe like BuzzFeed
where maybe people shouldn't be
shouldn't be worked to death yeah and
the Union does protect them and they
give them benefits or even an option to
join into the Union because I remember
when I was working in the hospital they
were telling me that you can decide if
you want to be part of the union or not
yeah some of them were like are like
fifty-fifty like my mom's old job was
like that so you're like when they first
was about to unionize there's a bunch of
people that wanted it there's some
people that that didn't want to but then
eventually the whole company became
Union and my mom was against the Union
because I think she felt a lot of
loyalty to the to the company and like a
lot of like people milk in the system
yeah it comes out and then but
eventually my mom's salary went from
35,000 a year to 85,000 she goes I've
kind of like the Union usually happened
that's when it's great yeah yeah that's
when it's great that's a big jump yeah
hey guys John what you we're doing the
same [ __ ] I'm like I'm like beat I'm
like 90/10 on unions I'm for them until
there's corruption and [ __ ]